moi je le dis toujours la charnière de
25 ans n'a rien à [ __ ] de patrick
chêne
mais quand elle rentrait dans la change
l'impression d'être le malade le plus
important du service
[Musique]
on a certains patients ont connu la
majorité ne le sont pas mais sans traité
d'abord tous de la même manière
et ça ne fait strictement aucune
différence dans les soins strictement
hockey un petit bémol sur l'accès aux
soins pas frictionne télévision jean
daniel flaysakier france 2 à o jean
daniel qui est qui est le meilleur
urologue de france c'est lui qui avaient
pu remorquer un jeune son téléphone allô
professeur parce que je peux me
permettre de vous demander rendez vous
oui appelé monstres et arrière voilà le
numéro ça m'a fait gagner beaucoup de
temps tout le monde a accès au soin mais
beaucoup moins facilement que moi mais
ça ça a été une différence ensuite en
revanche eu d'accord du proviseur quand
il s'agit d'être soigné tout le monde
est à la même enseigne
[Musique]
lorsque je retiens c'est la
bienveillance et c'est le mot capital
c'est à dire que ces gens qui sont
souvent en pressurisée qui avant faisait
partie d'un service
il était chez lui qu'il est le père mort
comme l'infirmière de blocs comme les
saisissent maintenant les mettre un
tableau excel est qu'ils arrivent le
matin il eut rien d'eux pour qu'ils
travaillent ces gens là ont conservé un
amour de leur métier et une
bienveillance extraordinaire pour le
malade
non seulement le métier n'est pas facile
en lui-même mais il est compliqué plus
en plus parce que on a tout un tas de
normes de procédures qui sont imposés
aux soignants et qui sont très souvent
déconnectés de la réalité et ça c'est
très problématique parce que ça démotive
les gens et d'ailleurs on voit de plus
en plus de personnalités kif l'hôpital
parce qu'ils n'ont plus de sens à leur
métier l'hôpital français reste quand
même parmi les plus performantes parmi
les saints des pays développés les gens
qui râlent quand même beaucoup il faut
le reconnaître en france se rend compte
quand même que l'hôpital est à leur
disposition qui n'est pas foutue
bien au contraire et donc c'est aussi
aux patients en nous renvoyant cette
image positive tous collectivement les
patients et nous de redorer le blason un
hôpital l'hôpital
on a un joyau il faut absolument
défendre et absolument être vigilant si
l'on va ça va faire que certains
services publics il faut bien le dire ça
va partir à vau l'eau est ensuite par on
fera des constats qui seront dramatiques